music is an expression there's an art to
sound the great part about music is that
it allows me to express how I feel in
the moment but if I want to change my
mood music can help me do that too like
I'm I feel mellow when I want to get
pumped I can do that it's why people tap
their feet or dance in a car you can't
help it it doesn't matter the song but
music can bring people together too when
you have someone that understands the
music like you do you don't have to talk
you don't need an outfit going okay okay
we're gonna do it this way instead the
music takes control the exciting thing
about dancing is that it's so
unpredictable freestyling you're
improvising you can't think about
anything else
I'm just here by myself with the music
get out of your head and into your body
trust your instincts well you really let
go that's the only time people actually
get impressed with what you're doing
you have to look for the logic in a song
for the anticipation you get inspired
seeing other people's choices when
moving to a song like I would never have
thought of doing that but watching
someone else that changes how you see a
song and it pushes you to try something
new
there is plenty of dance that was
created in a lab or a studio but the
best stuff was just created socially not
just one person expressing themselves
but other people responded you when you
can get a group of people moving
together in unison that's a different
thing the music becomes the leader for
each saying something different but it's
the music that ties it all together
[Music]